Tenpai, I saw you at school today I took your picture, man, I snuck away
I want you to notice me But I'm just someone you don't notice
Well, I think I've got a rival I have to kill
Please notice me, senpai Please notice me, senpai
Please notice me, senpai I am, there's no hope to die
My heart beats faster when I'm near you I get so nervous, I don't know what to do
I don't mean to seem aloof I've got to push another student off the roof
And I drag the body to the furnace To destroy all the proof, why won't you
Please notice me, senpai Please notice me, senpai
Please notice me, senpai I am, there's no hope to die
If anyone else will die, only you and I will be left standing
This one on my mind might not know why
Please, why won't you notice me, Senpai?
Please notice me, Senpai
I promise we'll have to die